Now.
Is there a place called the sugar factory? That's in the Hardrock hotel? Yes.
Did I go? Yes. Did I get ice cream? Yes. Was it good? Yes.
Then that I get ice cream at another place because I would try and test out all
the different ice creams in Atlantic city. Yes. Was it as good? No,
it was a closer. Yes. So did I go again? Yes.
Should I have gone to the sugar factory? Because it had better asked me. Yes.
Did I not know because of laziness? Yes.
There's nothing more.
Piggy than going and getting the worst ice cream because it's closer.
Go.
Take a few extra steps. You knew.
I'm rod, but I wouldn't.
Um.
So I went to go get the,
I went to the sugar factory and that ice cream was banging. Dude,
if you go to the hard rock in Atlantic city, that's just banging.
But if you go to the, uh, if you go to the hardware, if you go to the, Oh,
I got that. Don't get food there though. I got food there and it's,
it's so gross. It's so gross. I mean, don't get, I got the salmon.
Don't get the salmon at a place called the sugar factory.
Literally someone was like, Oh. Which some guy came up to me. He said, Oh,
what are you doing here? I was like, what do you mean? He was like,
are you an actor? Some. I was like, well, yeah, I guess. Sure. Yeah. Yeah.
And he was like, what's, y'all doing here. I was like, Oh, we're doing a movie.
And he was like, Oh. I already ordered the, the ice cream. And the,
the lady behind the counter goes like this, here you go.
And gives me the ice cream. And I said, cool, what do I owe you? And she says,
you're shooting a movie here. And I said, yeah. And she said, just take it.
I don't even deserve the parks.
You don't know me.
Took a regular dudes word for it. Just some guy with his chick.
What are you doing here? You shooting a movie. Yeah. Just take it
sad in a way.
You know? Wow dude.
Um, Atlantic city is hilarious.
Just straight up is zero. Good looking people.
Um.
I dunno. So Jersey though, like crazy,
incredibly Jersey went to, uh,
went to let me do these ads and then I'll do it. I went to, uh,
New Jersey or I went to Atlantic city and it's so it's S the Jersey.
We went to a place called white house subs. By the way,
I went to white house subs and there's a few white house subs.
And it was just silly. Like I mentioned it around a local,
which was annoying because I was talking to Garrett, my buddy Dylan.
And he, I was like, we got to go to the pistol by our subs.
Apparently it's really good.
My agent told me about it and the guy who overheard us as I, yeah.
But you got to go to the original. Now we know if you know anything about me,
my anger is a Ryzen.
Cause it doesn't matter about the original dude. It doesn't matter. I said, Oh,
why is it better food there? And he said, no, but the atmosphere and I go.
Hmm.
And then Garrett, of course, because he's a real person is like, well, you know,
let's go to the original. It's like, all right, we'll go to the original.
So we drove, he drove and the whole time he was like, I gotta get gas.
And I was like, you're fine. It's like one fourth. And he was like, yeah,
we're going to find a gas. I was like, you're fine, dude. We got there.
As soon as we walked in, it was,
Garrett says, man, there's a lot of Jersey faces in here. Huh. And there was,
everybody was talking about Frank, do you know what I mean? But that's not what,
that's not what Frank said.
I heard that 14 times while I was eating a sup out. It's not what Frank said
at us, not what Camon said, heard it 14 times.
And, and um,
I get there and the lady is like, you know what you want? And I was like,
now you've got menus. And she was like, sure, she's put down menus.
And then there's a half order and a full order out at white house subs.
And I was like, I'm gonna get the Turkey. You know how I do it?
I get the Turkey and the cheese of a medicine.
Plus I get a Turkey cheese because I want to rock it. I don't get the,
you know, other. I don't mix meats too much. An Italian sub is nice.
Let's not around in Italian. Sub is nice as. But the Turkey and cheese,
I mean, I would roll down a, uh, what do you call it? Ralphs.
When I used to have a, uh, when I used to live in my apartment,
I rolled down a Russ.
I'd walked down there and just go get meat and cheese dude.
And they'd be like, Hey, how's it going? Regular? And I'd say. Yeah,
meat and cheese. And I'd roll back. And I'd surprise my ex-girlfriend.
And I'd be like, I got meta cheese. Cause that's how we said it. Meta cheese.
Cause we thought we were cute. We broke up with both.
We both cried, but meat and cheese dude.
So now I get made of cheese. Anyway.
I mean in the about us section for white house subs,
there's a photo of the two guys who found it.
And the one of the guys is chomping on a
Stokey eh, Jersey,
or you want to take it.
The white house shop was opened in October, 1946 by Anthony Brasil,
along with his aunt Basilea and uncle Fritz
[inaudible] Jersey, Fritz,
you know, Fritz dude,
Uncle Fritz SoCo, S a C C O Fritz.
Isn't a name.
Fritz is like something that you're on.
If you're going through a breakup, dude,
Fritz is a noise that a cable like a broken cable would make Fritz Fritz for
threats. And that's your name? Dude? S Jersey. So,
um, in 1946,
our parents were committed to bringing you the best sandwich made with the
choice, CEUs meat, with the choice, choice it's choices,
choice it's Jesus Christ. Choicest meat.
Anytime you say meats,
that's so Jersey in Italian and we'll meet you one today. We,
the children are committed to maintaining that same tradition of excellence
created by our parents. Sincerely the Brasil and SoCo,
currently families and the white house gang
Bissell, along with aunt Basilea, ah,
sick and fusing the seal.
And Basilea most Italian lawyers of all time come on down to Brasil and Cecilia.
Um, so we went there and I heard, that's not what Frank said so much.
So there's the large portion and the half portion portion. And I said, yeah,
let me get the Turkey to cheese. She's like, you want the peppers?
And I was like, Jersey. Okay. And she was like, um,
do you, uh, do you want the full or the the half? And I said full.
And she, she looked at me and she was like, full is really big. And I said,
how big? And she's a fullest like that big. She goes like this.
She goes like this. Okay. I mean, and then half is Epic. And I was like,
Oh, she's just doing it too much because she thinks,
she thinks your boy can unhinge his jaw. You know what I mean?
Maybe I'm a boa constrictor. You put a Southern from you put anything.
I don't stop. I stop eating when there's no Mar
what's his. When people are like, ah, that's enough for me? Boom.
That's up portions, dude. How much did you make?
So I said, get me the largest is all right.
So they brought the large dude, what is that?
Oh, no
water.
Um, so, so they brought the large and uh,
is that going to be annoying on thing? Okay.
So they brought the large and it was, you know,
like if you go to someplace like a subway, if you get the large,
it's two halves, dude, it was four.
Ah, four.
And, um, and it was unbelievable.
And I was like, Oh no. And I didn't stop eating. I ate the whole.
It's gross. So gross.
And ate the whole thing. And Garrett didn't because he's a real person.